[Music]
right now parts of clark county under a
flash flood warning as storms bringing
that heavy rain and winds to our area
the flooding already causing some major
issues especially in the southwest part
of the valley a live look now from one
of the hardest hit areas at blue diamond
and rainbow that's where we find 8 news
now reporter jeremy j ford
that's right i am out here at blue
diamond and rainbow and water is
continuing to fall in the west it's
actually coming down and flowing east
and causing problems for drivers if you
guys look over here you can see this
gray or silver that is toyota avalon and
i spoke to the driver who was saying
that she was making a left-hand turn on
to rainbow and once she did the car
stopped trapping her inside now
emergency services were called and she
was rescued from the car but the owner
tells me she is currently now safe and
waiting for the car to be towed but if
you guys come over here what you can see
is that water continues to flow over
this ravine and it was possible that her
car could have actually slid off over
this embankment but luckily she was safe
i also had the chance to speak with
metro who tells me to be sure and let
everyone know that in storms like this
be sure to slow down and use caution
from las vegas jeremy j ford live local
now